depression is often misunderstood in the
public sometimes people think that
people with depression are weak or lazy
when in actuality people with depression
are struggling with a very complex
illness that has biological
psychological and social causes and
consequences depression is extremely
common it affects one in four women and
about one in five or six men and those
who don't experience depression
themselves often have a friend or family
member who are experiencing it the most
commonly experienced symptoms of
depression are sad mood and lack of
pleasure
people often know sleep changes and
energy changes and almost everybody I've
ever interviewed which would be over
2,000 people with depression all
experienced feelings of worthlessness
almost every single one depression is an
invisible illness it's not one that you
can see just by looking at somebody
normal sadness can occur in response to
life events depression at least in its
later stages tends to be disconnected
from actual life events so depression
and sadness share the sadness but
depression is so much more than just
sadness and as a matter of fact some
people think the worst part depression
is now experiencing pleasure there's a
numbness in how sometimes when people
have severe depression feel
pull yourself up by the bootstraps you
should get yourself out of this or
things like your life is great what do
you have to be depressed about
depression is definitely not related to
someone's character or moral
shortcomings and it's really interesting
to think that if medication can help
people who have these illnesses how
could it really be about their morality
depression can affect every aspect of a
person's life it can affect their job
performance their family relationships
their divorce rates are higher it can
affect their parenting abilities and
depression is one of the leading causes
of economic burden of any diseases
people are often surprised to hear that
it costs more to the society than cancer
or heart disease if depression goes
untreated it could turn out a variety of
different ways it could be that people
stay at the same sort of negative level
that they've been or sometimes it can
get much worse so it can with each
passing depression some people feel
worse and worse so that they might
approximately about 20% of people I
believe with major depression end up
making some form of suicide attempt so
the question is how do we get people to
feel better so that they can think
better or vice versa how do we get them
to think differently so that they can
feel differently
usually people come at depression with
one form of treatment or the other is in
they'll either go and get medication or
they go get psychotherapy or they'll do
nothing in fact the data support that
the best treatment for depression is a
combination of medication and
psychotherapy I think there's a lots of
strategies that people can use in order
to try to feel better improving their
sleep and sleep hygiene exercising 30
minutes a day is particularly aerobic
exercise seems to be very effective for
people with depression and for the
social piece I'd really recommend to try
to develop more social engagement with
people because again I think that's one
way that people can actually help
themselves to feel better the good news
is that depression is a very treatable
illness the majority of people who get
care particularly they can get care
early will end up doing very well